hello everybody mark a bar here and as
you can tell by the giant pile of mail
behind me that it is markiplier mail
grab manly maniac mail thing that
happens to be on a Monday I still don't
know what to call this thing so um help
me out on that one ran the comments for
a while we got to do okay you could see
that um the amount of mail that I
received today has been astronomical
that's not even all of it there's a pile
of letters about this big that you can't
see off-camera um and unfortunately I
can't go through all the letters but I'm
gonna make damn sure that I go through
all the boxes today this is going to be
like an hour-long video so if you don't
have like patience to sit through it
that's fine but just warning you right
now there's going to be a very long
video I'm going to open all the boxes
first this time and there are so many
letters set I'm just gonna have to pick
them at random to read them so sorry if
I can't read yours on air but I will
read all of them today I'm going to
spend pretty much all day long reading
your mail so if you guys were wondering
why I can't answer all my messages
online you send me this is why because
it's easy to send me an email or or send
me a message on YouTube in facebook
which I don't check anymore I don't
check YouTube and Facebook messages and
I try to check all my email but this is
why I can't respond to everything cuz it
would take up literally all of my life
to do so but anyway enough lollygagging
let's get started I got my super opener
because you guys wanted me to not pre
open them so I'm going to open all of
them on camera did a little one and by
the way if your address gets put on I'm
sorry it's a hazard of sending me a
package you may happen I'm gonna try to
avoid it but I will not actively do
anything to prevent it from happening
okay so this one is from Victoria
Falkner Victoria Paul yeah ooh what is
this ooh what is this I don't know but
it's it's a red box with something in it
but oh god you didn't make it easy for
me to open alright
hate it already Jesus what kind of tape
did you use oh you make it hard on me
you're making me look bad in front of
the internet here thank you so much
Victoria Faulkner but on damn whoa
you almost maybe hit my own record
button anyway it's a little dull I'm I'm
hoping this isn't a voodoo doll cuz it
kind of looks like that but God look at
he do look at him with a little beat oh
look at him that's obviously a handmade
doll so there's really cool oh there's a
letter too so I make sure that I at
least look at this alright this is a
voodoo doll whatever you do this doll
will happen to me Oh No firstly I want
to congratulate you on all your success
your videos have entertained councilís
of numbers by now you've probably got
about 40 million by now but if not then
this is an early congratulate gift it's
a little charm I made took me a while to
make it think of it as a kind of good
luck charm to help you in your times of
need while playing your games cuz I need
them all the time your faithful youtube
fan Victoria Emily
Faulkner thank you so much
alright I did not plan headwear I was
gonna toss these into the pile
afterwards but I'm already behind on
time so I'm just gonna have to chuck
them down there not that I don't think
of your gift very highly I just have to
toss them and go because I got a scalpel
here and I got things done damn open god
I hope there's no live animals in any of
these because they're about to get
stabbed you're all right this next one
is from Donald Van Hooten sorry I'm not
laughing at your name but that's just a
really funny name Van Hooten not
laughing at it at all but woah alright
your name not funny this guy Wow he got
me Gears of War judgment is that the
newest one I think that's the newest one
because I was under the stand
understanding that well I don't know
what that was but Gears of War judgment
he actually got me
is a war judgment I haven't played any
of the gears war games but I do have
this xbox that's sitting over here doing
nothing so I might give it a try that's
really cool gift or since it's already
prepackaged I might do a giveaway of it
cuz I'm not the biggest Gears of War fan
but all these games that you guys send
me since people want to send me games
for some reason I might actually collect
them and do a giveaway later because
obviously I don't hate games but you
guys could so I'll figure that out as I
go I wanted to thank you for don't for
so much for donating $50 during my 36
hour charity livestream for AbleGamers
foundation we did a charity raffle for
the prizes and you won oh I remember
this this is from D live two two eight
nine one he was another he's a fan of
mine that was doing this charity stream
and I always like to support these guys
who do charity stream so I I just
happened to run across it I did a tweet
about it and then I donated fifty
dollars to him because he was pretty far
behind on his goal I hope he made it I I
don't
oh yeah we ended up raising one thousand
eighty four dollars smashing our goal of
a thousand dollars it's really cool
congratulations guys and wow that's
amazing so thank you so much that's D
live two two eight nine one is his name
and he was streaming on Twitch so you
could probably find them if you searched
up D live two to eight nine one so thank
you so much but as I like I said before
I don't know what I'm gonna do with this
try not give it away if that's not too
much trouble so thank you into the pile
whoosh where's my scalpel
that's really cool because I mean I
never I never imagined I'd I think that
guy sent me an emo and I'm not sure if I
responded but like I said I can't keep
track of everything that goes on I try
to but I can talk a lot of things but I
do definitely I'll remember that and yes
I do I do like to go to other people's
charity events so if you got if you're
doing a charity livestream let me know
cuz i wanna i'll gladly support it oh
it's a little Yoshi oh the little Yoshi
oh so cool it's straight it's like from
Japan like legitimately from Japan
what is this oh is this the bomb is this
where I die it's just kind of a aluminum
foil taped thing I'm gonna put that over
there bubbles oh this is either a
tear-soaked envelope or something leaked
out of this bottle um you you did what
uh that's a phone number
hey hang on I gotta see this
smells kinda funny no offense of course
I'm just under different of course it's
it's I think something leaked out of
that bottle I'm not sure I can't oh
sticking to it I can't read this it's
all smudged up um I'll get to that later
what is in this bottle you all get to
see me explode on camera how about that
oh no never mind
don't think about that what is what what
is this what is this oh it's bubbles
that's what it is
oh man that's what it is okay it's a
bottle of bubbles
oh that's why the note said bubbles
aren't I'm not gonna finish unwrapping
that but yet bubbles your thing leaked
unfortunately and it smudged up your
letter but I got your phone number here
so yeah thank you so much for the Yoshi
that's so cool is this Yoshi's name
bubbles if it is that's amazing and I
love it so much
ed to the pile okay I'm gonna go throw
this into the pile but that gently over
there so it doesn't continue to leak huh
in one more yeah oh wow I stubbed my toe
oh all right here we go I'm getting good
at this unwrapping thing as ice mess up
a few times
yeah these boxes are getting bigger what
hey stop it
so I things are not cooperating off
camera you can't see but my team of elk
Jeremy well get to work ty they just get
unruly you know drunkards
don't burn Kurt al I don't even know why
you walk all right what do we got here
this is a big bag that make sure I don't
stab myself all right we got some
letters here oh my gosh that's a lot of
writing I'm sorry I don't have time to
read this on camera if I want to read
some other stuff but I will showcase all
of your goodies cuz there's a lot what
do we got here oh it's me riding a bear
punching Slenderman in the face that is
so metal that's so footin metal I can't
even understand it and we got I'm sort
of snack I don't know what these are
they're from some other part of the
country that I don't know takis Fuego
which means hot and Spanish don't know
what takis mean uh chosen itõs a
children oh is a type of food alright
anyway let's get to it an air freshener
strawberry air freshener I'll hang that
up in my car and we got a bear this is
the boy look at this
it's the bear with my t-shirt look at
that I'm gonna sleep with this mmm mmm
it smells good too
I don't know why but it does it really
does it smell they must have washed it
mmm that is like cool cool look at that
this is the bear that i ride into battle
facing Slendy so thank you so much that
it's like look at that look at our
that's the coolest thing that's cool
together thank you so much anything else
in there there's goggles I think they're
kind of like steampunk goggles too there
those are actually pretty cool Han let
me let me try those on sit you down
Bobby bear there's a bear of a name
there anything else in here oh there's
even more that's a
lot of stuff there's a markiplier
bracelet you can see there and that's it
okay I will read the letter later this
doesn't work with glasses does it I
can't see a thing it's blacked out you
didn't put ink on this in the inside so
they'd get all over my face with you no
you didn't don't get good I will that's
really cool I've never had goggles like
this I'm assuming that these are meant
to be steampunk but they're really dark
inside so meant for welding maybe I'm
not exactly sure but thank you so much
it was this by the way I didn't even
look at the name um Asia Feltner thank
you so much Wow but the bear stays over
here so thank you so much that's
incredible though more um it's like
Christmas every week for me alright I'm
just weeding from the top of the pile
down trying to get as many of these as I
could well I'm gonna get all the boxes
definitely and then I'll see how much
time I have left for the letters later
getting hot in my room actually all this
excitement get into me get on the human
oh right what do we got here packaging
material okay what else have we got
what is this no way it's a dead stop
it's a dead stop from Gamestop dead
space 3 t-shirt so large which is one
size too big for me but I might wear it
but then again I might added it to the
pile of stuff that I'll give away ok
what else is in here
haha it's my little pony
what are these there's a pony there's a
crystal shine Pony inside me collect all
I'm not a pro knee I appreciate the
sentiment I do I do I really appreciate
the sentiment would oh my god oh I've
seen these before I've seen these oh man
if only this was pink that would be
perfect but it's still awesome anyway I
should brought paint it pink I still
have my where to go haha I still have my
necklace a woman from last time so it's
pretty awesome if a one for the fact
that I couldn't see I might wear them
throughout the rest of them but man
let's go cool i'ma come up with these
right over here and that's it so thank
you thank you so much that is amazing
Nicole Kalina
Nicole Kalina thank you so much I mean I
I appreciate the sentiment on the pony
thing but I'm not gonna be turned into a
brony I'm sorry not that there's
anything wrong with being a brony but or
brony ER or someone who watches my
little pony but I guys he's not for me
but this is cool I like this I like this
a lot
Hado pile more you unscrew the chair
that's gonna kneel cuz it's too much of
a hassle to constantly get up and down
get out of here share I need you anymore
I've moved on I've grown up alright this
one is from no name but from Texas the
man with no name from Texas cliche
that's a song right anyway woo greens
nothing I love me some green stuffing
XLS Sooners a little more so you guys
can see my lovely face instead of what's
going on in the background there oh it's
another bear death what does it say I
love you and T UNT I love int I love
Oh University of Texas why isn't it just
UT the hunt University of North Texas
could that be it I don't know
I don't follow colleges fall college
sports but this is cool thank you you go
with the other bear thank you into the
pile there is a letter that I will open
later thank you
more now your screen stuffing Oh need
you anymore sorry I'm all over the place
because I'm there's so much to do and
I'm so little time
actually I don't know why I'm rushing I
got all the time in the world I mean you
guys wouldn't care if I uploaded like a
two-hour video would you nope no we
wouldn't marklar no we wouldn't at all
have the greatest thing ever I
understand I knew I knew that was okay I
knew it whew I hope you don't plan on me
returning this but it's it's um what is
this it's a cake of some sort from
jasmine and zaire Mead it says it's a
lemon flavored pound cake let me open
this sucker up for you guys I got so
much crap in here Yoshi my Yoshi fell
out of the box yeah go get it yeah mmm
it smells heavenly
hey and this so weird doesn't not what I
imagined I'd be doing oh that's good
mm-hmm good night I'm gonna get so fat
mmm mmm good I'm following my tradition
of eating on camera cuz that's what you
guys like to see
ah it was poison okay don't thank you
next ah yeah right this one is from
stuff fell there's just too much stuff
they all fell over the lace this one is
from swagger WS r SW e GE r Slager and
he has sent ah hat a Mario themed hat I
don't look good in hats but here it is
anyway it's gonna ruin my hair oh yeah
yeah that's the Alf I have a really big
head so hats don't always work for me
because I mean quite literally out god
well hair go back into a point yeah it's
good enough
alright I'm so professional anyway so
thank you for the Hat and also there's
just gigantic muffin and a letter and a
little itty bitty Mario figurine oh but
but go to the board man I love all the
cool press is having me thank you so
much wow this is crazy I wish I had more
time to spend on each one but I do not
all right we got one from rob em from
Pennsylvania how do I open this hole tap
to open I don't even need minute oh oh
no I didn't cut myself with my scalpel I
pinched it I'm putting the desk in the
box it really hurt hi Amy
whoa what the
we got t-shirts here what is that hahaha
uh-huh are you kidding me whoa hang on
hang on hang on hang on I got to see
this foul the hood is more there's even
more t-shirts this is so cool there's
one red one I'll open the red one cuz
then there's a bunch of white ones
a letter let's see
keep the shore girlfriends writing this
for me terrible eligibility I truly
deeply appreciate all that you've done
and all you aspire to do thank you so
much
shirts are contributing kinda the red
one that's all yours and the other three
you can do whatever you want with so I
might throw that the other three into
the giveaway pile but you don't know
what they are
oh this one's different than the other
ones but a boob someone to fan a drunk
minecraft so that that that is really
cool I like that and let me show you
what the other ones are because um
they're different and they're more me
ish they're more about me so maybe I'll
just keep them to myself but check those
out I think they're all larges how cool
is that well I mean it's kind of weird
cuz me but yeah it's almost like I can
do all the faces myself not quite though
I'm not dead animated anyway thank you
so much that's that's amazing and you
have your your of your girlfriend right
your letter for you uh uh Oh sweetheart
please drop this down for me I will give
those shirts away cuz you guys will
probably want them I'm not saying I
don't want them I'm just saying that
I've got extra shirts now and I should
probably give them back at some point so
thank you so much let's open one of
these big tubular ones huh no I
and roughly I'm guessing hang on hold on
put your horses hold on please
do the best I can here I'm not
professional in any way so just cool
your jets man
no no no Oh stinks please don't be a
dead animal please don't be a dead
animal I don't know how they would have
shoved a dead animal into a tube but
please don't be a dead animal where are
you huh
oh yeah we'll come out I'm trying I'm
really trying man will get their jollies
off for that one good that's really
stuck in there I can't take my hand to
doing my hands too big in it it's really
in there I'm guessing it's a poster of
some sort but it's like really Joker in
there maybe I should try to open it from
the other side oh I'm on time all worn
out now that always that usually gets me
so tired god
whoo-whoo yeah I don't understand
oh that really takes it out of me all
right okay
gotta open the other side it's it's the
tape that stinks it's not it's not this
it's just all the glue and what guys
enjoying this really entertaining show
we got going on here me grunting trying
to open this all right oh okay oh my
this is a poster please don't be
pornographic yeah let me show it down
here first
whoa this is involved that's a lot of
stuff um it's what what's my name and
it's a lot of Minecraft related stuff in
the edges and II shot their slender
they're up in top it's happy wheels uh
bottom cat Mario and then I will see you
in the next video bye bye
thank you so much who was that from I
didn't even look when I was tearing up
in that package um I'm still here miss
me
that was from I doesn't even say did it
say on the poster I'll check it later
thank you so much I'm running out of
time I've been doing this for already 20
minutes
huh and you got brought couldn't even
hear me most of it because I've been so
far away from the microphone but anyway
yeah yeah next okay oh all right
look at this goodbye boo boo tired it's
really tasted on me almost there Jesus
look at these impossible to open boxes I
don't even understand oh don't tell me
it's a tube in a box you're killing me
man you're killing me who are you who
are you this we're Marion Marion Sanders
oh you're killing me he's dude all right
whatever
there's a there's a mustache on it and
yeah I got open and now oh no no I'm
grateful I'm grateful oh all right
here it is don't know why you needed to
for that but let's see what the whoo oh
man there's like too much going on here
for me to even explain okay so it's me
up top that's yamimash to my uh if
you're the way I'm facing my right the
left on this one below that I don't know
who that is but on the right that's Bob
and on the bottom right I don't know who
that is but that's that's the sweet
angel lady to my bottom mmm oh she's so
fine that's just the killer dead and
he's you grunt dead slender Cubby's dead
a whole bunch of Castle Crashers guys
dead this is really cool I mean no
wonder you wanted to protect this so
much it's pretty much amazing Bob's
shooting an arrow into this
I'm guessing weight is one of these but
I'm not exactly sure which I don't know
but this is awesome anyway so thank you
Mary Ann sonders
sorry I was upset at you for getting the
redundant packaging but that's okay
because it doesn't matter so Dangs
they're really cool I'm not actually
hanging this up it's really cool put it
over here and all the crap packaging or
err okay next all right get this one I'm
still recording right
how'd suck if I like look back and I was
like for the past 20 minutes I am the
recording and I already opened
everything you guys would be pissed at
me if that happened oh okay what do we
got here what do we got here it looks
like a mug of some sort
all right and we got a t-shirt of
another sort which looks like invader
zim and it is what what that it's
invader adventuretime that's really cool
are they made by the similar creators or
is this just a happenstance that someone
created got a random thing but that's
really cool I don't want to adventure
time I've been told that I really should
but I don't want you Betty cartoons or
TV to begin with so I don't really know
but this this is cool I might add this
to the giveaway pile it's a size large
so it could always it could go go
for future reference on the size medium
okay all right I'll put that over there
the other t-shirts box over there thank
you whoa hey who was that uh who's that
Nicholas in Nicholas I Nicholas I thank
you so much Nicholas you're awesome more
I'll save the big one for last
whoops some other things why I had to
come with huh ah getting sweaty
oh that's moving around I mean to just
sing in a chair 12 hours a day exercise
is good for me it's not good for me whoo
all right what do we got what do we got
what do we got what do we got what do
you we have a letter read me yo that's
what it says please all right I'll read
you ooh
some silly [ __ ] up how
area whoa whoa I'm up it's another
mustache all right it is a picture of
the angel lady a picture of the person
has a potted plant picture of Slendy
picture the king of the squirrels and a
picture of person hugging me with also
some band-aids paper clipped onto there
so thank you so much now let's see what
else is in this package oh there's a
squirrel with a little animated big
moustache Oh looka dude a little cookie
oh look again it's so adorable hoot oh
oh and it's got oh no I thought he had
velcro arms and he could hug oh that
would have been perfect but still great
no matter what yeah it's got a handle
its tail as a handle so I could turn it
into a mug or a salt shaker son there
thank you
oh and I didn't open this other mug from
before but it's obviously a mug I'll get
to in a second okay what we got here we
got some sort of something peanut butter
that's what it is is peanut butter I'll
smear that on my face later and we got
pure maple candy that's and we got oh
it's a brain mold it's a brain ice mold
this is awesome I love these I love
these creative um ice multi it's
literally it's you can see its shapes
and when you put water in and you cover
it up it'll freeze into a brain that's
so cool I love that that is the greatest
that's like the coolest thing I've ever
seen in one of these I had a makers mark
one before but I mean it broke so this
is really cool thank you so much to me
yeah this is leaking why are they always
leaking maple syrup it's maple syrup
okay how about put that in there that
was leaking unfortunately but I'll get
to that later now let me get to this mug
now that I missed from the last box
and it is it's the same thing no no no
no no no no I know all right thank you
thank you guys so much I'm guy I've got
so much stuff here I just don't know
where to put it so I'm just gonna end up
having a bunch of junk in my room bunch
of trash that I have nothing to do with
all right okay next oh yeah two more
smaller boxes here and how do we open
this one how do we how do we oh here
like all the why can't they have some
uniform boxes I mean a lot of these are
from the post office but they're all
completely different why do you need a
different magazine I don't know I don't
know what is this um I'm not sure what
this is
ooh oh no way
these are so rare it's the PC version of
Silent Hill CD one two and three
the PC version of Silent Hill is
extremely rare it doesn't really exist
anymore this is so cool I've been trying
to get I had the xbox room but it was so
buggy that I couldn't play through it I
might do a let's play of Silent Hill 2
now dananananana
and doesn't dad that's so cool I there
on the e babies cost like $100 is crazy
let's see I recall yeah Silent Hill no
longer have need of them own two copies
of the game uh you'll take time to play
off camera yeah I will play these no
matter what and I might just do finally
do a Silent Hill 2 let's play which I've
been told do so many times so that's
that is that is that is quite awesome
thank you so much this is an incredible
gift so thank you thank you
oh man this you guys are so amazingly
generous to me I really don't know how
to say thank you enough let me write on
oh who is that from yeah I keep
forgetting to read those from Scott
Clark thank you so much Scott Clark you
are awesome
brute force I'm guessing there we go
yeah uh so okay good move finger that
right uh-huh
go plastic bag mu plastic bag blue
plastic bag blue plastic bag there's
something else in here what is this it's
a My Little Pony brony bracelet still
not a brony
but that's cool anyway and it's got a
ooh a moustache Auto opener that's cool
oh that's really awesome I might
actually use it I've been I've been
needing a bottle opener so oh yeah
and so many plastic bags you could have
picked two smaller box to send that in
but either way that's so cool there's
other stuff in here too alright my
markiplier drawings please read the back
my name is Megan Megan not Megan it
sounds like Regan
oh this is me this is this is what I
tweeted him
I want a markiplier tweet me and an Xbox
wish granted one of them at least from
me so I don't remember doing that but
apparently I did so you're welcome
Merry Christmas let's see
oh wait have I seen this before oh I
almost ripped it no one saw anything
alright so we got oh I remember this
yeah I remember seeing this before
because I couldn't remember actually
saying this I actually asked like did I
say that this is from the great work I
couldn't remember if I actually
shattered in us it was like did I say
fettuccine alfredo in response to one of
the bouncers and apparently I did I
don't even remember saying it and then
there's this drawing which is really
cool I saw this on the deviantART and if
you have fan art please post it to the
leaving art so wait hang up oh oh oh
it's almost an exact likeness oh all
right okay someone sent me a text but I
don't have time Bob Bob is texting me
right now Bob I don't have time I'm
literally swimming in fan mail right now
I cannot handle this I can't handle all
this there's just too much I we're
almost through though we're all austere
okay alright
get in there get in there get in there
okay time for the big one oh the big one
this is the big one you're not even
gonna be able to see me open this so I
got to pull everything up this is the
bomb this is one is the bomb that's
gonna kill me it's awfully big one
that's what she said
case you didn't know
I like cheese's and there's one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
wait 1 2 3 4 50 yeah 10 boxes of
cheez-its
how did I get so fat aah oh yeah oh oh
Jesus she need to send me money uh uh oh
I just I would have I had two empty
boxes of cheese's in here before oh oh
oh oh gotta get it together market wire
don't let it go to your head
don't let the delicious cheesiness go to
your head ah oh ah okay there's also a
letter in here I'm pretty sure it's
self-explanatory
here's your cheez-its enjoy your bath
cuz I'm gonna pour this all the bathtub
and no eat it later
okay so I've watched your videos since
July of 2012 and I think you are one of
the most inspirational people on YouTube
you have such great talent don't know
about that great heart by hosting
charity drives on your twitch for that
here is a huge box of cheeses to show my
dedication to you whenever I feel down I
just watch one of your videos to cheer
myself up you will honestly be my
favorite youtuber for all eternity and
you will be my favorite person Marc Mac
Monroe not Marc consider playing ex
mortis - yeah I meant to do that a long
time ago I kind of forgot about so I
need to get today cuz I played ex mortis
one and I know there's two other sequels
so I get
to get to that but let me just organize
these cheese's I might have smashed up a
couple I'm sorry I didn't quite yeah
take care
in my explosion of orgasmic cheese
Ignace so thank you so much I gotta put
this no more oh all right okay that is
all the boxes that's all the boxes that
I have but there's still more mail still
more still more mail so oh now we got
the smaller envelopes that I need to go
through so let's start opening them up
this one is from Daniel Spinelli
Daniel's been a Lee Daniels beanie oh
come on
alright whatever I'm just gonna have to
rip this open come on there yeah it is
oh no Pamela oh it is fan art and
there's someone else in here sorry it's
just a packaging sword
open and there's a letter in there whoa
alright that is some fan art that's
written on some type of cloth type paper
the sketch paper is very thin and easily
torn I can see it's very it's very very
flexible but it's still cool look at
that look at that look at that look at
that
okay my name is Daniel and I've been a
fan of yours since your slender videos
in August I think you are incredibly
funny and talented and entertaining I
don't know about that I try to watch all
your videos you upload them every day
you have built an amazing community
through your live streams and donating
to charity I personally feel honored to
help you reach your goals with this
channel also I am so happy you finally
got a peel box I've been working on this
drawing for weeks more like a few months
and I'm so excited to finally send it to
you I hope you like it thank you for
everything you do
Danielle thank you alright
oh so much amazing stuff that I I feel
bad because I'm just throwing it all in
a pile over here but I'll clean it up
and organize it later open with care fan
art inside from Stephanie Van gird
Winegard
Oh me as a pony that's weird
no offensive they are really do
appreciate but that's a strange all
right I don't have time to read all this
but a skim over my name is Stephanie 20
year old psychological student
psychology student congratulate on being
such an incredible example of what a
youtuber should be I'm so immature I
don't think that's true but I deeply
admire everything you're able to do it
can only hope to someday achieve what
you have through your channel no matter
what know that you are loved by everyone
whose lives you touch your genuine
kindheartedness and one-of-a-kind style
have led you this far and I know you'll
be able to do so much more as time goes
on much love from Northeast Ohio
Stephanie winegar she be cakes on
youtube so thank you so much
alright rush this one's from Amazon
someone buy me something else something
else I need to give away god it's so
hard to open oh no it this I was just
doing it the wrong way I am gonna start
sweating soon what is this it's another
pony I'm not about it I'm not I'm not
I'm not a rodeo oh no no oh yeah yeah
okay so thank you for the pony into the
pile okay this one's a bigger bigger
envelope from from Lucinda Lord from
London is Islington London United
Kingdom Wow
sounds very official let's tear it open
see what it is
it's another pony I swear I swear it's
another phone
whoa what is this got pink on it but
it's all skulls and whatnot yeah and
what what the hell what the hell or him
I'm not sure if that's hammer what the
hell yes what the hell okay
no peeking turn me over and open have
sanity potion lantern and law down to
dumb on standby read me first okay let's
read this what is this not sure what it
is but whatevs
okay um see you safe and sound live
fangirl epoch ah City a longtime viewer
and subscriber is money kudos to you bra
photo of new giving thanks you in a
painted piece of fan art the photos in
here it's not a photo of her there's a
painted piece of fan art no peeking
alright how do I open this without
breaking it it's a good ya carried over
kind of apprehensive to see what this is
whoa whoa
awesome I'm not gonna show to you but
that is amazing dude this is like this
is amazing this is incredible I mean
this is like the greatest thing I've
ever seen doesn't matter I'll show to
you it's it's a painted grunt as a gamer
that is like really cool ah he's as
scared of you as you are of him except
that he'll kill you first
ah the likeness is uncanny oh thank you
so much is really well done this is like
unofficial canvas painting thingy that
is so cool does oh cool
oh right next smash just want to break
that so I don't have nightmares nan okay
so thank you so much lucy lord
yeah all right more more more MORE
there's a lot of little packages now I'm
pretty sure that I'm gonna wrap this off
after I get through these so let's just
tear through them real quick so that I
can get you guys can get on with
whatever you were doing today on your
April Fool's I was gonna do something
for April Fool
but I didn't have time after I I stopped
by the the the post office early this
morning and it was like oh my god I
don't have time for anything else
ooh ooh look at this say uh set fix it's
a bead pixel art of em and there's some
advertising for you right there
la la la la to store where they can sell
these I'm guessing where you can buy
these if you want it's a keychain so you
can have a little keychain em on you I
might actually use that too if it was a
bottle opener too in my band just
kidding thank you so much okay and I saw
this it was like please read read read
read read important please read Markab I
read read read so I'm like okay so let's
read this but if you're gonna grab
attention like this I'm gonna make fun
of your letter the entire time I'm right
hand just for warning you just preparing
you for the inevitability of me mocking
you mercilessly for your incessant
attention-grabbing efforts this will you
would you deserve I'm skilled I'll be
nice all right ah gonna spend that much
effort to try to get my attention I
might as well look oh my god it's a long
letter oh my goodness oh wow
um I can t it's very hard to read it's
faded it's like almost faded to
blackness and smudge but oh this way
this actually looks like some personal
stuff here um there there is there is
some here that's personal so I'm not
going to make fun of any of it at all
there's like seriously some pretty
pretty pretty serious stuff going on
this letter so I'm going to read that
personally later and not on camera but I
did get it and it did read it or I'm
going
ciara Peters from ceará Peter so thank
you very much my computer just freaked
out so I will be back real quick okay
we're back sorry I just had to make sure
because I've been recording for like 45
minutes and if my computer crashed or
something I didn't want to me I didn't
want to lose everything so I stopped
everything so I could go right back in
okay moving on to more cool letters ooh
this one's all gold it's very fancy
very fancy yeah mark
Oh see honestly I can't even begin to
thank explain how thankful I am for you
I've been bullied a lot since last
school year I was depressed and some
days wouldn't even get out of bed your
videos always make me smile and feel
happy I guess I could say your videos
are what keep me alive seeing you get
freaked out amuses me but really thanks
so much for being you I don't know what
I'd do without you you're like my best
friend to me you are the best mark I'll
Andrea I'm 13 and in seventh grade I
really hope I get to meet you one day
you were my hero sorry about sobbing
right so I can't write you back
said write me back maybe but I can't but
I read it so there you go so you're
welcome and there's some other stuff in
here to see here mark bar big mustache
yeah something else here some fan art
yeah drawings was this a I got your
pages Slendy can't let you do that I
need those for a meeting
that's my Slenderman voice I know I've
never done that before but that's my
official Slenderman voice so thank you
so much I hope things go better for you
in terms of being bullied but it's weird
because I never imagined people writing
a lot about how they've been going
through depression and my videos help
them at and I never understood that but
I'm really honored that like it does but
I don't know how but if if it can help
I'm more than happy to keep doing it so
thank you guys
alright we good woo
oh it's a mass effect lanyard or
whatever you call these things that's
cool no something
another Pony God don't not brony
I'm nah what am I gonna do now my room
Pratt can be filled with all these the
pony memorabilia and uh like you play
one game you play one game and they they
just come out of the woodwork I'm scared
I really got out there to get brony I'm
just not one see you're very
entertaining a terrible person those you
know you personally are fortunate the
rest of us fangirls will have to admire
you from afar don't ever tell us if you
get a girlfriend it'll break our hearts
okay so thank you so much for the pony
and the mass effect lanyard I I forget
what these are called but thank you
are you moving on I just got a few more
I gotta get through them as quick as
possible
let's see and that took five a b-52 ship
that's a lot and it's got Slendy on the
on the back they're so good more make
sure that was known oh come on
hey Mack ah there we go
sorry sorry if I ripped anything in here
let's see it is beads bead bracelet bead
bracelets this one's got a dice on it
weed bracelets and there's also a letter
in here see Dimock my name is Gabrielle
I have only been subscribed to you bro
for a few weeks but I have enjoyed every
video you have made I'm thinking about
becoming a let's player myself and would
love to use my channel for good just as
you do I know if you've heard it a
million times but you're truly an
inspiration I love your creations of
pure terror just as much as your sense
of humor personality and kindness stay
awesome and never forget your roots far
too many have forgotten their beginnings
best wish Gabrielle thank you
I'll wear these bra
oh boy a box within an envelope
alright come on come on come on back oh
oh it's from Mary Kay what is it what
what what what what is it oh it's
another bracelet okay mark flyer my name
is Tanner 16 and my brothers all love to
watch your videos I noticed that you are
a portal fan I'm shooting you shipping
you an honorary Aperture Science test
subject bracelet cool it's desktop again
it's actually a from aperture so yeah
I'm gonna wear that yeah yeah get that
on there
yeah I'm piling stuff on my rib so thank
you so much all right
one more come on gotta keep moving god I
keep why do you take these up so much
they're already sealed yeah hmm here we
go
cool it's a big poofy mustache it's a
big pink poofy mustache
thank you so much who is it from that is
from Pierre mo lanky Pierre mo longi
deer market by my name is Rachelle you
just said your name was Pierre alright
whatever
let's say you have such a great channel
and devote so much time charity and
laughter I'm sending you this pink
mustache as a token of my appreciation I
look forward to watching many more of
your videos sincerely Rachel or is it
Pierre uh-huh that's what I thought
you're Pierre to me so thanks Pierre for
the big pink mustache you're the best
glad you're a fan all right
huh oh come on good I'm a tear up my
fingers just trying to get these done
all right what do we got here yeah
letter and some pages lots of pages lots
and lots of pages here I'm assuming
these are drawings yes mostly drawings
comics actually oh but Agrippa I only
have an up
oh it's drunken minecraft amnesia that's
Agrippa I can't go through all these
right now but I will go through them in
a bit
it's about crafting to try to get out of
a muse that's basically the gist of it
so thank you so much I will get to these
in a bit but there's also a letter oh
man there's a lot of stuff oh my god
it's an essay let's see huh how are you
doing today I'm doing all right um your
your name is where are you what is your
name name is Katie Rid DeNooyer readin
Euler so I I literally can't read all
this on on paper I will read it later I
will I promise I will I promise I will
read all of these especially the giant
stack of mail that you haven't seen yet
and it is gigantic you might think that
I'm close to done but if you count all
the letters that I've gotten I am
nowhere near close to them so thank you
so much and I'm sorry I couldn't read
all that I literally do not have time
we're approaching an hour here all right
what do we got it is an envelope that
has bunch and bunch bunch bunch bunch of
I heart mustache on it and there is what
is this just it is there's a cutout
mustache and butterfly stickers and and
another mustache and it's mark as a cat
it's me as a cat better than me as a
pony but it looks like someone who's
trying to drop me at the pony before
they scratch it out
and then it's another attempt at me as a
pony but it's crapped out - okay good
then there's me with what is that on my
little pony cat or really fat my little
pony cuz that's hilarious and then
there's Slendy and Jeff the killer down
there your likeness is uncanny okay so
thank you so much almost through almost
true so much stuff here so much stuff
I'm sorry I am a cluttered mess you're
the reason why people are gonna think
that I'm a hoarder all of you oh you're
the reason oh this one's really cool
because it's got a Slendy on the back
there no no no no no no no no I hi guys
all guys I don't think any of the pages
just said eyes eyes eyes eyes eyes eyes
eyes because he doesn't have eyes he
doesn't take people's eyes but I don't
think he does
alright good boy okay dear mark hi I'm
13 year old boy 14 in May who is an
artist and a big fan of yours I've been
a subscriber since Auto August and since
then you've changed my life when I'm
down you always seem to make me feel
better
I'm sending you a token of my
appreciation I'm not down I'm laughing
my butt off I'm sending it a token of my
appreciation it's some fan art which I
really hope you like of course I like it
tah-dah mark al-arian the mustaches man
people it wants to come obsessed with
mustaches from Mark blaring a mustache
it's amazing how just the one character
a Worf - made it like an iconic thing of
my channel I mean I haven't even
introduced that since you know the fall
Slenderman again so ah it really becomes
something bigger than I thought it would
be so thank you so much I'm drowning in
mail but thank you I'm thanking you as
I'm drowning okay try to get this strip
all right what have we got here
someone send me a dollar yeah one dollar
this is actually here is a dollar for
saving my life and helping to return my
smile so I'm going to read this
oh dear markiplier thank you for all the
Cancer Fund livestream and all the
wonderful video you do you have changed
my life in so many ways when I first
started to watch your videos I was at my
last leg with life after years of
bullying and being raped oh my goodness
oh man that that's horrible I'm so sorry
falling into five to six bad
relationships I was done with life then
I saw one of your shows I was scared
happy laughing the pain seemed to just
disappear like magic I had forgotten how
to laugh and smile if my Popo was still
around I am sure he would thank you as
well also with this letter is a picture
of pinkie pie your favorite pony I
didn't then see pinkie but where is
Pinkie Pie I am she Pinkie Pie is it
this way no oh yeah that's it for pony
stuff alright so anyway that's cool
thank you so much I'm glad that I could
help I I mean it's really it really is
strange for me to hear these things like
I have saved people's ID because I don't
think that I'm that influential but if I
have somehow in some way managed to
change someone's life for the better
that's it's really really really an
honor and I don't feel like I'm I'm
worthy of that kind of praise but thank
you nonetheless it's it's just
incredible in so months and a dollar a
whole dollar thank you so but yeah that
really means a lot to hear that you know
I've managed to do something good with
all of this so like seriously thank you
you don't need to thank me thank you
it's good to know that I have some sort
of purpose in this and
and moving forward I'm actually going to
contribute something okay there's just
one last one last thing that I need open
here oh no I just tore the letter oh no
I just tore the letter oh my god I just
tore the letter
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry it's a $5
Starbucks gift card I don't really drink
from Starbucks but that's cool
nonetheless it's a boo pixel-art oh is
it from the same person who had the oh
she won ow
Mike ow ow I really just rammed my elbow
into my desk and it really hurts but I'm
tough I will go find out the same person
but so that's pretty awesome it might be
I don't know let's find out oh wait
there's more there's a $25 Olive Garden
gift card that's pretty cool and there's
a $25 Applebee's gift card wow I'm gonna
eat good hit this week and I'm so sorry
because I literally just I literally
tore the letter when I was opening that
and I I don't usually do that but you
could see I tore the whole side up but
it didn't it didn't affect any detects
oh all right enclosed is a companion for
the Yoshi egg you two received yes it is
ha ha ha ha boos the first perler bead
design that I made it didn't turn out as
nice as I wanted what you're talking
about it's great hopefully you'll like a
regardless I also flipped in some gift
cards for Applebee's Olive Garden
Starbucks the first two or 25 and
Starbucks is five I really don't have
any use for them so I figured you could
use them as on a future date
I want the Applebee's garden a drawing
and all the card was given to me by the
manager because I complained about the
service discussing Mexican drug wars and
cocaine around the children I don't know
if you like Starbucks but if not you
could always pass it on to Bob or Wade I
also wanted to say thank you for all
that you do in a big congrats for
200,000 subscribers I've been watching
your channel since 30 K and I'd be lying
if I said I wasn't amazed wishing you
the best Sarah Carter so thank you so
much and wow there's been an hour-long
opening of boxes and boxes got so much
stuff oh my god on this one I missed oh
I missed a box yeah I can open this Oh
like it's in there it's really in there
that's pretty deep in there
that's another poster and a letter dear
Mac I hope you enjoy this piece of art
that I work it's really it's in cursive
with rotary I worked hard on when you
announce you have a peel box I
immediately began drawing in this
picture I drew monster from dead space
eerie portal Sunderman cilenti Toby's
pokey slender and SCP containment breach
the median is charcoal so please be
careful with it I hope you love it from
your fan amy some last name that i
cannot read let's see whoa whoa dun dun
dun da da
wow that is that's crazy that is cool
thank you so much thank you so much
I gotta be careful with that one so
thank you again Amy Amy Amy Amy
I think that's Amy I better sit Amy wait
there's a postscript slenderman's face
ripped a little when I sprayed it with
fix lived oh well and sorry for my silly
handwriting just trying to be fancy like
your pink mustache and your your nose
was a [ __ ] to draw lol you need stuff
on your wall okay
thank you thank you Amy I really do
appreciate that you are the bomb as my
friends it's Indigo's day alright that
is it that is wrapping up I actually
couldn't get to actually couldn't get to
reading any of the other letters other
people sent me but do not worry I'm
going to read them after this but I will
read them all personally and just man
huh this is this has been a very
involved video to do let me just show
you guys what I'm talking about here
this is how many letters I have that I'm
going to be going through after this
video is over
oh this is why I can't read them all on
air it's crazy like maybe I'll just save
some and maybe the next time I do a live
stream I'll do I'll read some of these
so um but I'm going to read them all
personally so Oh seriously you guys are
amazing I never imagined this this
response would happen my post office
hates me but you guys are still just
fantastic I love each and every one of
you you guys are the greatest
inspiration for me to keep going that I
could possibly imagine so seriously and
honestly thank you guys so much for what
you've done to help me in and I'm glad
that I could help some of you I never
imagined that I could in the ways that
you guys have described so seriously
honestly and truly thank you guys so
much I hope you had fun seeing all the
stuff that people sent me I got a lot of
stuff to go through now and I've got a
lot cleanup to do but anyway thank you
all seriously so much for watching check
the description for my peel box if you
got more stuff to send me I'm gonna keep
getting it I'm gonna keep opening it so
seriously honestly thank you guys so
much you are the best fans that I could
ever ask for
so thank you again and as always I will
see you in the next video bye